well as those gusty winds picked up  those thousands are thousands of feet  high in the air felt the impact landing  at harry reid international though  flights were not delayed significantly  we did go over to the airport as crowds  were touching down earlier tonight many  describing a very bumpy ride  like i felt like i was very nauseous it  was really scary landing and  i mean honestly i know we fly in and out  of vegas and we know it's always bumpy  to get here but this was just like  really scary there was really nothing  you could see on the floor except for  maybe like a mountain here there bumpy  up and down shifted to left right  definitely nausea people were kind of  and when we landed a whole bunch of  people started clapping thought we made  it safely  a handful of flights are delayed until  after midnight so if you do plan on  flying out soon be sure to check your  flight status